[Music]
sure you could serve a drink on the
usual rocks what are you some kind of
barbarian Ice Cube's melt too fast at
least that's what some bartenders say
something about surface to area ratio
but a sphere now we're talking
put ice cubes into the cocktail Kingdom
professional ice ball maker and the
energy generated between the weight of
the heavy anodized aluminum mold and the
ice crafts it into a perfect sphere
just be careful melt water is going to
spill everywhere prices steep to about a
hundred and fifty bucks but that's what
one good bottle of single-malt it makes
for an awesome looking drink just be
prepared for the ice to bonk you in your
nose when you take it
[Music]